nick jonas this is your first normal
live experience how does it feel to be
here for your first normal live
experience it's good you know this is
the
the fun part of the show for us and the
whole journey of the season because
uh it's now up to the country to decide
who goes on and
so our work is kind of done you know
apart from helping pick some songs
working with our artists that move on in
the competition
but tonight's the the first of of these
live shows and it's my first time doing
it
on the actual set so it should be should
be a good time with all of that being
said how would you assess
your chances of winning going into these
lives is
well i feel very confident my team i'm
very proud of all the work that they've
put in
and you know the start of my team after
the blinds when you first assemble that
team
there's so many gifted people so many
talented artists and so to have to then
cut that down to the smaller group is so
tough but
uh it just it's it's it's the show right
it's what we do it's it's part of the
journey and so i'm so grateful to have
had the chance to work with all the
artists and
and now to see who who moves on is is
going to be interesting
who's your biggest competition as a
coach who are you most worried about
it's varied you know in my first season
season 18
uh kelly and i were going head to head
quite a bit and then uh
this year john and i actually went head
to head a few times in the
the uh blind auditions the battle rounds
and um
and i beat him two times to win an
artist so i was very very proud of that
not that i'm counting
but i did count one thing that we love
about this show is it's kind of seeing
the evolution of your bromance with
blake shelton
and you and your brothers have always
expressed this interest in
doing country music have you blake ever
talked about possibly a collaboration
he and i have never talked about
collaborating on country music he wants
to start a dance troupe
oh lord but he doesn't know that i'm not
a dancer by any means
um so that's probably out of the
question because i've seen him dance
it's not good are you guys are you guys
recruiting for a fourth jonas brothers
member
well we have a fourth jonas brother he's
not in the band so blake would have to
be the very
uh old um uncle jonas in the background
yeah you know obviously blake is very
busy right now planning his wedding
and you are someone who knows a thing or
two about
wedding celebrations yes plural do you
have any advice
for him uh well
for us we just planned it really quick
and then it all worked out
it all came together um but for for gwen
and blake i mean i i
i don't know i'm sure it's gonna be a
fun night i'm sure there will be lots of
wonderful beverages uh in involved and
i'm i'm
so happy for them i wish them all the
best and if you tried to recruit you as
the entertainment or maybe you and your
brothers would you say yes
very expensive so i said we are very
expensive so blake
you know we got to dish it out